welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the upcoming Daredevil Born
Again series just got a major timeline
update events of this series will be set
during the blip as well as a number of
flashbacks that jump around to several
time periods which makes sense for 18
episodes like I don't think you summer
children with your six episode Disney
plus series or even your 13 episode
Netflix series are ready for the haul
the marathon of living four and a half
months with something but as a kid who
grew up with yearly September to May
seasons of Lost I can promise you it is
awesome and the fact that at least part
of Daredevil born again will be set
during the blitz suggests that one of my
favorite things of MCU phase 4 like the
Monica Rambo flashback to the hospital
or the Elena Bulova flashback and
Hawkeye to that bathroom blimp fiction
is coming to Hell's Kitchen this has
been a huge opportunity that Marvel has
rarely taken a swing at to go back to
one of the most fascinating periods of
their history Ryan coogler wanted to
explore the societal ramifications of
the blip in his original draft of black
panther 2 but of course had to
completely change that movie and now
Daredevil born again is the perfect
place to explore what the world looked
like during those five years and how
Wilson Fisk Rose to power or maybe we
should say Rose to power again and how
Matt Murdock got to the place where he
was defending Peter Parker and flying to
Los Angeles to debate superhero Prophecy
with She-Hulk and debate other things in
privacy with She-Hulk so production for
Daredevil born again is currently
underway in New York with several set
photos and set videos giving us daily
morsels of what to expect from this
series we learned that John berthal is
returning his Frank Castle Punisher and
that the character of Vanessa fist has
been recast with Sandrine Holt replacing
ayolette zurer who played Vanessa in the
three seasons on Netflix also that Eldon
Hinson and Deborah and wolf will not be
returning as foggy Nelson and Karen page
at least in this show we don't know yet
if they're going to be recast recently
once that photo showed Charlie Cox as
Matt Murdock in front of a Christian
parish for Spiritual renewal the
announcement board dated March 15
2020. now in general MCU projects tend
to be very deliberate or at least very
vague with any visible dates shown in
their sets Hawkeye set photos showed a
happy New Year 2025 sign that they ended
up covering up when that episode came
out and Miss Marvel included a health
inspection sign and food truck that
dated the show in spring 2025. so
setting this scene in March 2020 was a
deliberate choice for one in our real
world timeline it's right around when
the world began to shut down for covid
but in the MCU this is right in the
middle of the blip which began in May
2018 and ended in October 2023 in the
MCU timeline now if all 18 episodes of
Daredevil Born Again take place during
the blip saying that foggy and Karen
dusted could be one simple answer as to
why Henson and wall aren't showing up in
the season but it's also possible that
only part of these 18 episodes will
flash back to the blip era and that the
rest of it will take place in whatever
the current MCU period is as most Marvel
titles tend to do that would make it so
that Echo could still show up on the
show as her character was introduced
during the events of Hawkeye which was
set in December 2024 and we know marvel
wants us to identify the MCU Daredevil
with that Hawkeye era because even in
his cameo in She-Hulk in Los Angeles his
scene with Jen in that parking lot had a
billboard for Rogers the musical in the
background now I grew up on Batman and
James Bond but as much as I love the
idea of a gadget-filled belt I don't
want to leave the house every day with a
bunch of bulky stuff taking up precious
pocket space all I really need are my
wallet and my keys and ridge has me
covered on both fronts for 10 years now
Rich has been making minimalist gear for
those of us pocket Warriors who don't
like the idea of carrying a sack of
stuff with us every time we leave the
house their wallets are slim but still
have room for up to 12 cards and cash
and fit in any pocket you've got with
room to spare plus you can choose a
design that suits your Vibe Ridge key
cases fit up to six keys and keep them
all tucked away so you don't have a
bulky gently lump in your pocket every
day how somebody didn't think of this
the day keys were invented I don't know
right now Ridge is celebrating their
10-year anniversary with a massive sale
so it's the perfect time to upgrade your
pocket game just go to ridge.com new
rockstars right now and you can save up
to 40 through March 24th that's
ridge.com new rockstars to save up to 40
between now and March 24th so if Matt
Murdock was around in March 2020 of the
MCU timeline it means that he survived
the snap and that he existed in a New
York City where there was no Spider-Man
in Queens where there were Wales in the
Hudson City Field vacated no Mets games
boats moored up at Liberty Island by the
Statue of Liberty group therapy sessions
hosted by Captain America and their
surviving Avengers Upstate New York
tracking earthquakes under the ocean and
Rhody and Natasha following the
massacres of Clint Barton of criminal
groups around the world including parts
of Wilson fisk's criminal Network it was
a quite uncertain time that we still
don't know a whole lot about but with
fewer Avengers Level Threats shaking
things up it would be a perfect time to
explore the criminal operation of Wilson
Fisk gaining the upper hand in the
street level vigilantism of the devil of
Hell's Kitchen and the legal efforts of
Matt Murdoch protecting ordinary
citizens during this dark time that
street level impact is part of what made
season one of Daredevil on Netflix so
great it took place in the direct
aftermath of the battle New York it made
reference to that a number of times and
the various construction projects in
Midtown Manhattan that Fisk was
coordinating were contracts secured
after the events of the 2012 Avengers
born again could do the same thing but
in the aftermath of infinity War we
could see what Daredevil does after Nick
Fury dusts and drops that pager and
after a helicopter crashes into a
building does he spring into action like
Ben Affleck and Metropolis during the
opening a Batman v Superman whoops I
have to like played Daredevil in Another
Universe I think I'm making things more
confusing but you get the point I think
we all really want to see some Daredevil
blip fiction Now set photos have
suggested the 18f PS it's important
again we'll jump around to many
different time periods like set video
around a Hell's Kitchen Superette shows
kids and clothes from the late 70s or
early 80s which some speculated could be
showing a young Wilson bisque if so that
would retcon the character's origin
shown in season 1 of Daredevil on
Netflix there is also a photo of a prop
stack of newspapers with a headline of
EgyptAir crash that killed 217 people
this is Egypt Air flight 990 which
crashed on October 31st 1999. so there
might be a separate flashback showing
characters and they're used at a
different era it has yet to be confirmed
how exactly born again will connect to
the history we saw in the Netflix
Seasons Vincent D'Onofrio recently
tweeted indicating the soft reboot
Charlie Cox at d23 confirmed this would
not be a fourth season of the Netflix
series gonna be totally different it's
going to be news stories and new ideas
and and it's like Kevin said it's a
season one it's not season four really I
think this
and this is very doable in the MCU is to
just imply that the basics of what
happened between Murdoch and Fisk in the
three seasons on Netflix were all
canonically true for the MCU universe
but it's all backstory that the
characters just don't reference that
often we get a few supporting roles
recast and we get new flashbacks that
revisit other parts of their pasts for
example if the MCU Daredevil series
wants to just say Ben Uric is alive
again I don't think any of us would be
too upset the Netflix series killed him
off way too early I get that it could be
hard for some to conceive of an MCU
Daredevil that has been soft rebooted in
a way that makes sense but I think
that's just because those three seasons
of the Netflix show were so clearly in
our minds that's the reality we're
living with currently it's just kind of
hard to see a different reality that we
don't have yet but I think once born
again is here it'll all be much less
complicated so let us break down the
recent timeline of Matt Murdoch in the
pre-2018 period this would be the
implied backstory from the Netflix
continuity Matt Murdoch defends Frank
Castle in court Fisk spends some time
with Castle in jail Daredevil Works
alongside punished at the end of season
two to briefly fend off the hand Fisk
uses a doppelganger Daredevil in season
three is a fake Daredevil to try to free
Murdoch and at the end of season 3
Murdoch gets this and Vanessa arrested
now we would have 2018 to 2023 perhaps
shown on Daredevil Born Again showing
Matt Murdock in New York during the blip
blip fiction then November 2024 Matt
Murdoch defends Peter Parker against the
feds and actually helps out foggy Nelson
in some deleted scenes followed
immediately by December 2024 Wilson
fisks makes the move in Hawkeye as the
head of the track suits and a colleague
of Eleanor Bishop he ends up shot by
echo in the face but presumably survives
that just as he does getting shot by
echo in the comics wearing the same
outfit and then in 2025 Matt Murdoch
needs a new suit and visits La squares
off against She-Hulk in court over
Superior privacy and hooks up with her
this would be a timeline slightly
altered by Kevin the robot in ways we
don't fully understand and now we would
fight ourselves in 2026 in which
presumably some of the events of
Daredevil born again will take place
assuming Echo comes back and they want
to set up Daredevil in the present day
MCU but here's my question for you how
much of Daredevil born again do you want
to be set in the present day MCU how
much of it would you prefer to see as
blit fiction reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and he can
support us by grabbing submerged at nerd
riot.shop follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]